so thank you very much
thank you very much for the kind
invitation to speak this afternoon I
will be brief I just like to start by
saying that the context of this
doctor'll training center goes back to
the mid-1980s between the mid-1980s and
2005 the main source of funding for
doctoral training for students who could
get stipends and fees paid was through
European Union programs of research
where students would be embedded in
research programs and therefore get
their fees funded for their PhD and then
in 2005 the UK Parliament House of Lords
Science and Technology Select Committee
held an inquiry on science and heritage
in which for the first time it
recognized the risks to the UK of
actually not sustaining funding for what
it coined as heritage science which is
much broader than conservation science
because it included archaeometry
building science archaeological science
as well as conservation science so it
was a much more broader umbrella term
and the recommendations from that
committee have led to a 7 million pounds
fund seven-year programme for research
including doctor'll training funded by
the public purse for the very first time
and much more recently since 2014 this
doctor'll centre so the doctors centre
which for short we call see how science
and engineering in arts heritage and
archaeology was established with letters
of support from over 50 institutional
heritage and industry partners many of
whom are actually supervising doctoral
research projects today and here I've
just given some examples to your left
are examples of industry partners
and to your right some of the
International Museum partners and
heritage partners more broadly so the
funding stream works that the majority
of funding is from the engineering and
physical sciences research council which
is which funds research but in our case
is funding the Center for doctor'll
training it has given the majority grant
it's for eight years and we are
contracted to train 60 PhD students in
heritage science we have 55
institutional partners a mixture of
heritage and Industry and there are
three universities collaborating
university college london and i'm the
director of this program the University
of Brighton and the University of Oxford
since sep tember 2014 we have also
leveraged an additional 1 million
dollars from industry and heritage
partners and we have 19 funded
studentships so far so the way that each
each student ship works its valued at
120,000 pounds or about 170,000 dollars
for four years and it's a public-private
partnership two-thirds of the funding is
public partnership and the third is
funded by the industry or heritage
partner and this includes a 3,000 pounds
yearly budget per student for research
expenses and fees and stipends the
tripartite supervision works in the
following way the students currently in
the student ships currently involved 18
companies because two companies are
actually one company is contributing to
two studentships and these can be from
multinational companies to small and
medium-sized companies and and sometimes
they can may be about four or five
employees in the company and 19 heritage
Institute
asians and the tripartite supervision
means that the students would get their
normal academic supervisors which is to
a primary and the secondary supervisor
but in addition they must have a
heritage supervisor and they must have
an industry supervisor and that enables
them to develop their interdisciplinary
and transferable skills which will
enable them to work not only in the
public sector indian universities but
possibly also set up their own
businesses or work with industry so the
projects cover a wide range of topics
under one or more of the following
research strands materials where the
main focus of the students study will be
at University College London environment
where students who major in that area
would go to university of oxford and on
the Digital side where they would go to
the University of Brighton but because
it's a four-year program the first year
is always done as a master's course at
University College London so they sued
ins enjoy quite a unique research
learning experience they have a range of
supervisors from different backgrounds
which is challenging for the students
they actually have to engage in
dissemination and activities as a group
so they are not their typical PhD
students where they have a one-to-one
relationship with their supervisor and
we have a state-of-the-art scientific
facility which is a mobile heritage
laboratory which is not only enables
student to do advanced analytical
techniques in the field but it is also a
vehicle for public engagement so its
main purpose is to engage the public in
heritage science so finally the close
collaboration with the partners is
providing students with valuable
transferable skills from project
management to negotiation skills through
having to negotiate among the
requirements of different
stakeholders and also time management
and in fact for partners a modest
investment can deliver considerable
research benefits and I finish with a
quotation from one of our industry
partners who has said of one of our
students the solid ground work that hend
who is one of our Egyptian students has
developed and proven at UCL is now being
converted to high efficiency directly
coded algorithms at the Gildan photonics
which means that her work has actually
enabled them to improve their imaging
capability and the service that they
provide to clients which is great
because that's what we want to do we
want to show that the students are
relevant thank you